notre analyse avec rorum Chantal qui est
un spécialiste de la Chine qui est
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'Université de Mountain et Olivier
Bilodeau qui est directeur de l'équipe
de recherche en cyber sécurité chez GO
secure donc vous voyez on va parler de
cybersécurité géopolitique en même temps
dans ce dossier là parce qu'il y a les
deux messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir et est-ce que de bannir TikTok
chez les fonctionnaires pour une raison
de sécurité nationale rorum Chantal
d'abord est-ce que c'est justifié
mais pour démontrer que c'est une mesure
justifiée il faudrait connaître tout
d'abord fait la démonstration que
l'application est utilisée soit dans le
cadre d'une guerre de l'information par
le gouvernement chinois ou encore à des
fins d'espionnage ou encore que Tik Tok
soit un outil utilisé par le
gouvernement chinois pour exporter la
censure c'est-à-dire
bannir supprimer certaines informations
on n'a pas fait cette démonstration et
le gouvernement du Canada a ses contenté
de dire qu'il s'agit d'une mesure
préventive or on avait suffisamment de
temps puisque ça fait quelques années
qu'on en parle les Américains ont déjà
pris cette mesure et aujourd'hui où nous
nous parlons aucun gouvernement n'a fait
la démonstration de l'existence de cette
je dois être en désaccord ici parce que
ce qu'on sait c'est que l'application a
accès à ces informations là dans les
téléphones des individus donc
localisation télémétrie autre
application sur le téléphone et ces
informations là sont envoyées donc à by
dance dans le cadre de du fonctionnement
de l'application est-ce que le
gouvernement chinois a accès à ça si on
ne peut pas dire c'est là l'enjeu et le
défi je pense de de faire ces
allégations là donc c'est facile de
prouver techniquement par la
rétro-ingénierie que les capacités sont
dans l'application
une fois les informations envoyées dans
le cloud dans l'Info numérique est-ce
que ces informations là maintenant sont
utilisées par by dance d'une façon qui
serait contraire à ce que eux disent il
y a pas nécessairement moyen de vérifier
sans envoyer des gens faire des
vérifications dans leur centre de
données est-ce que c'est un enjeu
technique est-ce que c'est un enjeu de
cyber sécurité ou rorum Chantal vous
pensez que c'est davantage un enjeu de
géopolitique et de tension entre la
Chine et le Canada notamment je pense
que ce qu'il s'agit d'une mesure
politique qui reflète effectivement le
nouveau contexte de géopolitique
monsieur Bilodeau a tout à fait raison
sauf que il faut que mentionne aussi que
Tik Tok a quasiment accès au même type
d'informations mobilisées collectés par
ses concurrents en Occident donc il y a
ça c'est vrai aussi qu'on sait qu'en
Chine il existe un rapport différent
entre État et société maintenant dans le
cas de Tik Tok les mesures qu'on a
annoncées ne se sont pas fondés par
exemple sur un analyse poussée de
l'histoire de l'organisation de sa
structure organisationnelle et de ses
motivations en tant qu'entreprise
commerciale pour se demander est-ce que
véritablement TikTok tout en étant une
compagnie chinoise ce livre est à ce
genre de pratique c'est à dire donner
communiquer des informations aux
autorités chinoises d'autant que les
informations auxquelles Tik Tok a accès
ne sont pas vraiment des informations
qui concernent la sécurité nationale en
général justement sur la sécurité
nationale est-ce qu'il y a un enjeu de
sécurité nationale dans les données
qu'on peut collecter avec TikTok auprès
des utilisateurs
là ici je dois dire avec Tik Tok mais
aussi avec Twitter à mon avis un enjeu
de sécurité nationale on peut avoir la
situation l'emplacement des gens
lorsqu'ils utilisent l'application donc
si ils utilisent beaucoup l'application
on peut savoir ils sont où ce
matériel-là pour des hauts
fonctionnaires fédéraux ou des gens dans
l'armée peut devenir une information
très critique pour la sécurité nationale
peut servir à faire par exemple du le
mot vient juste en anglais
malheureusement mais du blackmail donc
d'essayer de dire on vous a vu on sait
que vous avez une maîtresse on vous le
prouve maintenant on va vous convaincre
de ton de tomber de nous donner des
informations privées sinon on va révéler
ces informations pourquoi on s'inquiète
davantage de ce type d'espionnage là ou
pour une entreprise chinoise que pour
Twitter ou que pour les entreprises qui
sont possédées par les géants du web
américain
je pense qu'on assume un bon mentalité
occidentale aux compagnies comme Twitter
et meta qui possèdent bac qui est
Facebook
qu'on donne pas nécessairement à by
dance qui est chinois puis la loi le mon
collègue pourrait probablement mieux
l'expliquer moi la loi chinoise est très
musclée par rapport aux accès qu'ils ont
droit de demander aux compagnies alors
qu'aux États-Unis il y a de la
transparence obligatoire il y a des
mesures aux États-Unis au Canada aussi
là où il y a une espèce de transparence
avec les utilisateurs alors ce serait
quoi les conséquences forum Chantal sur
nos relations diplomatiques nos
relations économiques avec la Chine et
la réponse de la chaîne aussi
mais évidemment
s'agissant des relations entre le Canada
et la Chine ce sont des relations qui
vraisemblablement vont continuer à se
détériorer il faut se rappeler seulement
que le Canada a publié il n'y a pas
longtemps sa stratégie indofacifique
c'est une stratégie qui vise
manifestement à contenir la Chine dans
la région Indo-Pacifique donc depuis
l'affaire Mango et la décision du Canada
de limiter l'accès de certaines
compagnies chinoises à certains secteurs
de son économie qui sont jugés sensibles
et la relation a continué à se
détériorer donc maintenant ce qu'il faut
ce à quoi il faut s'attendre c'est que
tout d'abord la Chine pourrait décider
de représailles de mesures économiques
comme elle l'a fait dans le passé pour
punir le Canada mais enfin la Chine
c'est quand même une grande puissance
avec des relations privilégiées avec
beaucoup plus de pays dans le monde que
même les États-Unis est mort je vous
conseille de sécurité avec droit de veto
à l'ONU elle pourrait
à l'avenir essayer de nuire à certains
objectifs du Canada sur la scène
international Olivier Bilodeau est-ce
que
est-ce qu'on pourrait interdire
totalement Tic-Toc au Canada pour tout
le monde
à mon avis non j'ai fait la décision
personnelle en faisant une analyse de
risques et mes filles sur la scène
téléphone cellulaire ontectacle donc je
crois qu'il faut vraiment penser au
risque puis c'est un risque d'enjeu de
sécurité nationale pas nécessairement un
risque personnel sauf pour le volet
désinformation mais ça ça se combat de
d'autres moyens Olivier Bilodeau rorum
Chantal merci pour cette analyse ce soir
merci au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI